from 1,500 feet above Hong Kong still
seems to be what it is long be a
spectacular modern monument to money and
success it's the way the people here
still want to picture it but now of
course the reality of Hong Kong is very
different below there is anger anxiety
and no little fear I lived here for
seven years before and after the
handover to China
everyone knew difficult times lay ahead
but never did I think we'd see live
rounds used against violent protesters
but I've returned to a place that's
bitterly divided divided between those
who think the protests have already gone
too far and are provoking the
authorities and more dangerously China
and those who support the protests
because they think Chinese interference
here is already too great and the view
up here is that it is even splitting
families this man told us his parents
are very worried about the protests they
do agree with their hearts in many many
families relationship in this family a
daughter who supports the protesters and
a mother speaking up for the police this
is a good control already things is free
freedom yes if we become a part of China
and all the law may be changed nightfall
brings nervousness here about the
protests about China and about what
tomorrow will bring